bonjour merci de nous avoir rejoints
d'enfiler qu on commence tout de suite
avec les grandes lignes de cette
émission
mardi 180 cortèges défilaient dans toute
la france pour s'opposer à la réforme
des retraites
nous avons suivi des syndicalistes et
vivra jusqu'à paris trois ministres en
visite dans les yvelines et ce lundi le
gouvernement veut montrer que les
contrats d'avenir sont une mesure qui
fonctionne c'est la période des foires
aux vins l'occasion de s'intéresser au
marché du vin dans le département ce
sera le dossier la semaine
et puis nous aborderons les difficultés
dans le secteur du bâtiment
notre invité thierry lorho pardon
bonjour vous êtes le président de la
capeb 78 donc la confédération de
l'artisanat et des petites entreprises
du bâtiment où une mobilisation a lieu
demain vous nous expliquerez vos
revendications
on retrouve donc tout à l'heure on passe
tout de suite à l'actualité économique
de la semaine
l'art avant 13h au technocentre euh
pardon la réforme des retraites c'était
l'objet de la journée mobilisation ce
mardi 10 septembre nous avons retrouvé
des syndicalistes évinois mobiliser des
images d'elodie moines mardi 13h au
technocentre renault à guyancourt
six salariés s'apprêtent à rejoindre la
capitale en bus quatre syndicats ont
lancé une journée de mobilisation
nationale contre la réforme des
retraites
et ces syndicalistes sont bien décidés à
répondre à leur appel
14h30 le début du cortège est parti mais
nous syndicalistes se retrouvent bloqués
dans les bouchons
en fait on va descendre pour rejoindre
la manifestation à pied très
prochainement puisque en fait là ça
avance plus beaucoup d'intérêt à ce
temps le cas
un peu de marche à pied et voici bernard
et ses collègues sur la place de la
république la fin du cortège est bien
loin de quitter les lieux
chacun se fraye un chemin jusqu'à son
syndicat mais peu importe leur couleur
les revendications sont les mêmes
le refus de l'allongement de la durée de
cotisation et le financement choisi
aujourd'hui quand on nous dit on va
laisser la retraite à 60 ans touche que
au nombre d'annuités c'est de la
fumisterie
finalement il propose d'augmenter les
cotisations pour les salariés mais en
bloquant les cotisations pour le
patronat que c'est des nouveaux cadeaux
qui sont faits au patronat dans le
cortège on retrouve de tri viennois avec
cette manifestation il espère faire
pression sur le gouvernement et la
majorité
avant le débat parlementaire prévu début
octobre la loi en ce qu'elle va passer
dans la mécanique on est actuellement
mais c'est vrai que nous sommes ce
prolongement du nombre de trimestre on
ne peut pas l'accepter parce que de
toute manière on ya déjà deux réformes
en cours actuellement c'est la troisième
on me dit toujours c'est la dernière on
se rend compte que tous les deux ou
trois ans on en remet une couche et on
recule toujours l'âge du départ moi je
vous dis à bientôt en vue de problème de
retraite aura plus de retraités sont
repris comme ça les manifestants
réclament notamment que cette réforme
soit financée par un impôt sur les
revenus du capital
en france ou comptabilisées de 360 à
500000 personnes mobilisées et la
mobilisation a également un peu perturbé
les transports et l'accueil dans les
écoles le gouvernement a lancé ce jeudi
34 plan de reconquête industrielle 3,5
milliards d'euros devraient être
investis pour renforcer les innovations
françaises et sauver ou créer 480 mille
emplois parmi les secteurs concernés les
transports dans les yvelines un
département aéronautique et automobile
nous suivrons cela de près le
gouvernement envisage de soutenir les
véhicules à pilotage automatique le
développement de bornes électriques ou
encore les avions électriques
à noter pour le moment les ventes de
véhicules électriques sont en baisse 403
véhicules en août contre 1350 en mars
trois ministres se sont rendus dans les
yvelines lundi l'objet de leur visite la
signature d'une convention 2500 emplois
d'avenir avec la fée ap une fédération
spécialisé dans des centres de soins à
but non lucratif des images de jonathan
willeman 1500 emplois d'avenir d'ici fin
c'est ce que promet la fée ap la
fédération regroupant les organismes
sociaux médicaux privés à but non
lucratif pour marquer cet engagement
trois ministres se sont rendus à la
verrière dans une unité de soins
gériatriques ici six jeunes ont été
recrutés comme brancardier
après une visite des lieux les ministres
se sont entretenus avec eux beaucoup ont
enchaîné des petits boulots avant de
s'engager dans le milieu médical
avec ces contrats d'avenir ils
obtiennent un cdd de 30 mois une
formation sans change que j'en avenir
plus sûr ouest judge en bourse par
l'outrance et bien sans pour le joli
l'état s'engage de son côté à financer
une partie des salaires à hauteur de 75%
du smic ainsi que la formation pour la
fiap ces aides facilite grandement le
recrutement
en tous les cas c'est une incitation
extrêmement forte qui doivent qui fait
qu' on ne peut pas passer à côté
mais je ne sais pas répondre à la
question de savoir si on en rit
employeurs n'aurait probablement
employés - tout à fait clair l'objectif
reste cependant de reconduire ses
nouvelles recrues une fois formés en cdi
pour le gouvernement cette mesure est
une des clés pour contrer le chômage des
jeunes et les objectifs devraient être
atteints dans les yvelines et sur des
chiffres on est un peu évidemment
plusieurs centaines doit être autour de
700 emplois d'avenir en france on doit
être tous rhône a projeté 50000 emplois
d'avenir c'est con à mi course
le gouvernement espère atteindre les 100
mille embauches en france d'ici la fin
de l'année sur le territoire de saint
quentin en yvelines de bonnes nouvelles
pour la rentrée tout d'abord bill
emplois supplémentaires avec l'arrivée
du nouveau siège de mercedes france à
montigny le bretonneux mercedes qui a
donc quitté au concours le chantier
touche à sa fin la pose de la fameuse
étoile emblème de la marque est fixé à
la fin novembre et la livraison du
bâtiment pour le mois de décembre
toujours des emplois supplémentaires
cette fois du côté du crédit agricole
une extension est prévue pour accueillir
1000 salariés
de plus la pose de la première pierre à
guyancourt qui lancera le chantier est
fixée au 22 octobre
à noter également un nouveau magasin
leader price a ouvert ses portes à
guyancourt le 4 septembre il sera doté
d'un drive ce qui est assez rare pour un
magasin de ce type les travaux devraient
se terminer la semaine prochaine ces
bonnes nouvelles ne font pas oublier
deux dossiers sociaux du moment
la session d'euriware le centre
informatique d'areva à guyancourt
les syndicats sont très mobilisés sur la
question et notamment la restructuration
du groupe eads implantés notamment à la
clé saint-pierre à elancourt enfin à
houdan un boulanger connaît une
notoriété fulgurante il participe cette
semaine à l'émission la meilleure
boulangerie de france nous sommes allés
le rencontrer un sujet réalisé avec
patrick jacques de dixmude
il est 8 heures jean-luc est aux
fourneaux depuis maintenant plus de
quatre heures des horaires difficiles
mais ce travail le passionne depuis
maintenant 30 ans sa boulangerie y est
situé à houdan mais la renommée de
jean-luc a largement dépassé les
frontières de sa ville depuis le début
de semaine
lundi on a pu les découvrir dans
l'émission la meilleure boulangerie de
france sur m6 inscrits par des clients
il fait partie des 84 boulanger
sélectionnés dans l'hexagone je me suis
retrouvé dans la sélection des musiques
croyait pas trop je me demandais ce qui
se passait je pensais qu'il y avait
plusieurs boulangers de ma ville - et
non vous êtes le seul élimine donc la
grosse pression
parmi les épreuves il a dit préparez des
spécialités de la maison vous présente
la nuque atos meilleurs jeux que j'ai
fait pour l'émission donc c'est une
brioche au yoga avec des briseurs de nos
gars de l'abricot sec - le pardon et une
brioche qu'il a créé lui-même face à
deux autres boulangers il a su
convaincre le jury
prochaine étape la finale ile de france
diffusée ce vendredi à 17h35
pour le moment il savoure sa nouvelle
notoriété des clients affluent de paris
ou encore de chartres pour jean-luc
c'est aussi le moyen de créer de
nouvelles vocations
ça va faire découvrir dans ce métier
parce qu'il a été beaucoup délaissé à
une époque par les jeunes parce que
c'est un métier difficile pour
travailler le week-end pourrait la nuit
tout mais en même temps c'est un beau
métier
le matin je suis au travail et jean-luc
cherche d'ailleurs à grossir son équipe
l'appel est lancé
victoire ou non lors de la finale à cet
artisan continuera à réaliser ces gestes
quotidiens avec plaisir on place des
bacs à 6 kg et après la machine et
divise pour une répartition des proches
je me sens sur un surhomme peut-être pas
mise en passionné oui le secteur du
bâtiment se mobilisent
des manifestations auront lieu demain
dans le département et dans toute la
france
et c'est l'objet de l'entretien de la
semaine thierry lorho bonjour bonjour
vous êtes le président yvelines de la
capeb la confédération de l'artisanat et
des petites entreprises du bâtiment
alors la capeb lance demain une journée
mobilisation pour alerter les pouvoirs
publics sur les difficultés de votre
secteur
or justement quelles sont ces
difficultés eh bien nous avons déjà
alerté le gouvernement depuis le début
de l'année c'est pas notre première
manifestation gagner une mobilisation le
18 janvier tout à fait pendant laquelle
nos élus
nous ont affirmé avoir entendu nos
messages et malheureusement nous sommes
aux deux tiers de l'année et on voit
bien que les messages n'ont pas été
compris alors une grande revendication
c'est la tva qui doit augmenter le 1er
janvier 2014 pour passer de 7 à 10%
elle était à cinq et demi pour cent elle
est passée à 7 maintenant à 10 au 1er
janvier 2015 qui va-t-il en être on sait
très bien nous artisans depuis des
années que l'augmentation de la tva
c'est une incitation au travail au noir
de les clients il leur pouvoir d'achat
va prendre elle veut diminuer ses 3 % de
pouvoir d'achat en moins donc la
situation tout à fait d'ailleurs bon
enfin tout le monde l'a reconnu de trois
ans après que ce soit les directeurs de
services fiscaux
même les ministres que la baisse de tva
de 19,6 à 5,5 n'avait quasiment rien
coûté à l'état parce que on avait
indiqué une grosse partie du travail au
noir pour 5%
le client prend pas le risque de prendre
une entreprise avec laquelle elle a pas
de facture pas de garanties
donc ça avait été en plus les chiffres
d'affaires du coût des entreprises ont
augmenté donc de l'impôt sur les
sociétés tout ça a couvert quasiment
l'intégralité des 14 15 % de baisse de
tva avec la création de 50 mille emplois
aujourd'hui on a perdu dix mille emplois
en 2012 on prévoit d'en perdre vingt
mille en 2013 probablement mais cette
augmentation de tva va continuer même si
elle n'est gère reprise d'activité va
continuer à faire diminuer le nombre de
salariés à un autre point je pensais à
la concurrence finalement s'éteindre
avec l'autre auto entreprenariat on a
deux types de concurrence effectivement
l'auto entrepreneur si vous me permettez
j'aimerais le v1 une méprise sur la
position de la capeb vis-à-vis de l'auto
entrepreneur qui se sent un peu
persécuté par nos propos l'otan avec ses
stations tout à fait mais avec le statut
pas avec l'auto entrepreneur
entreprendre
nous sommes des entrepreneurs nous
sommes favorables à 200%
mais c'est le statut qui nous qui nous
gêne parce qu'il est totalement injuste
par rapport à celui de nos entreprises
et là par rapport à la noce charge notre
pression fiscale et sociale
voilà pascal parce qu'à décharge en moi
voilà c'est finalement au on le sait
finalement les auto entrepreneurs ou un
chiffre d'affaires très faible est ce
que il vous faut vraiment la concurrence
oui tout à fait dans le bâtiment c'est
90 milles
entreprise entre auto entrepreneur dans
le bâtiment qui réalise du chiffre
d'affaires ce sont des auto
entrepreneurs qui sont malheureusement
dans des situations précaires mais qui
en attendant enlève du travail à des
entreprises qui eux ont des salariés qui
aujourd'hui avait des situations pérenne
et qu'on se retrouve à être obligés de
licencier parce que la quantité de
travail elle n'augmente pas on augmente
le nombre d'entrepreneurs mais pas la
solution ça serait du coup de supprimer
ses statuts pour votre secteur pour nous
ça serait la solution d'une part d'un
point de vue économique et ensuite parce
que le bâtiment a quand même des
contraintes très particulière en termes
de sécurité de formation une
installation électrique c'est dangereux
pour l'installateur pour le client il
faut que ça soit réalisée dans des
conditions vraiment très bonne et on
n'est pas sûr que les entrepreneurs
auto-entrepreneur soit tous forcément
électricien quand il ré l'île ce genre
d'installation et puis je pourrais vous
citer la même chose pour le gaz pour la
couverture pour avec thil nécessité dans
le bâtiment d'avoir des assurances
quand même pour le client l'assurance
responsabilité civile assurance
décennale et je peux vous dire que pour
les avoir rencontrés
je pense que 98 % des auto-entrepreneurs
dans le bâtiment n'ont pas ces
assurances ce sont des assurances qu'ils
coûtent très cher avec le chiffre
d'affaires que les auto entrepreneurs
déclarent ils ne peuvent pas se payer
une assurance décennale
qu'en est il si non de la limitation
dans le temps vers le statut et bien
alors ça ça serait éventuellement voilà
une négociation avoir une limitation
dans le temps un an maximum je pense
qu'en un an on se rend compte si on est
capable de
de gagner sa vie de générer un chiffre
d'affaires suffisant et de passer le cap
pour devenir une entreprise
traditionnelle
ça serait amplement suffisant trois ans
c'est beaucoup trop long
alors justement sur ce point où on avait
reçu en fait une auto entrepreneuse une
ancienne auto entrepreneuse qui a monté
sa propre entreprise
on avait réussi en juin dernier sur ce
sujet de l'auto entreprenariat je vous
propose d'être débouté son retour
d'expérience puis on reviendra reviendra
dessus juste après le statut d'auto
entrepreneur ne convient pas à toutes
les activités en tant qu'éditeur j'ai
des frais importants d'imprimeur de
salon de déplacement etc
donc je ne pouvais pas les déduire donc
c'était fossé alors ça un statut que
j'ai apprécié parce que il permet
effectivement de tester
une action en toute sécurité j'apprécie
aussi que le seuil au delà duquel on
doit basculer en entreprise à l'époque
l'état s'est élevée donc ça me donnait
quand même une certaine sécurité
mais c'est automatiquement que j'ai
basculé en entreprise parce que
fiscalement ça ne convenait pas donc
j'ai bien entendu ce qui a été dit
vivent de part et d'autre mais je suis
persuadé que dans le cas d'un artisan de
quand il commence vraiment à se
développer de lui même il va changer de
statut parce que l'auto entreprenariat
n'est pas très protecteur non plus au
niveau social donc bon voilà c'est mon
expérience mais je suis une obligation
dans le temps que donner votre avis je
pense qu'elle se fait tout naturellement
elle se fait tout naturellement mais en
france on étouffe déjà avec un carcan de
réglementation de législation pour une
fois qu'on avait un espace de liberté
peut-être pas le sucre et roshi donc on
l'entend pour vous pour elle en fait
finalement la limitation se fait
automatiquement
et il y a aussi finalement des droits
que les auto entrepreneurs non pas oui
oui tout à fait c'est l'exemple type si
vous voulez de la bonne utilisation du
statut de l'auto entrepreneur c'est de
dire voilà je ne me rends pas compte de
la viabilité de mon idée je la teste
mais voilà très rapidement je me rends
compte que ça fonctionne
et dans ce cas là effectivement je passe
dans un statut traditionnel ou faudrait
finalement obliger tout le monde à part
cette limitation dans le temps
finalement passer directement en
entreprise
alors on revient sur un petit peu donc
vous
ce que vous voulez proposer donc une
baisse de la tva
vous allez plus loin finalement que
refuser la hausse de la tva à 10% en
janvier prochain
vous voulez qu'elle revienne à son
ancien taux à 5% tout à fait pour tous
les travaux de rénovation du bâtiment
c'était une tva qui convenait tout le
monde qui nous convenait qui convenait à
nos clients qu'ils évitent nationale a
conservé une autre proposition peut-être
de la libération du foncier alors
absolument nous souhaiterions que alors
là bon c'est peut-être des lois mais
aussi les communes augmente les
coefficients d'occupation des sols par
exemple de façon à ce que des
particuliers qui ne peuvent pas un
tiennent plus d'autorisation voilà des
trains peuvent pas déménager pour
acheter plus grand
en région parisienne le foncier très
cher éventuellement de faire des
agrandissements
on arrive à la fin de cet entretien
juste un mot sur la mobilisation de
demain je crois qu'il ya des
ralentissements qui vont être prévenus
sur les routes notamment sur la n10 et
l'a13
tout à fait nous partirons d'orgeval
vers versailles par l'a13 et versailles
paris perd la nationale 10 à petite
vitesse
et puis nous retrouverait du coup le
préfet mois lors un entretien avec lui
j'aime voir la couleur et par lula de
vos revendications
tout à fait et bien je vous remercie
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau avec
halo merci à vous bon passeur on passe
maintenant à l'eau magazine de la
semaine
vous l'aurez remarqué c'est la période
des foires aux vins ne nous sommes donc
intéressés au marché du vin dans le
département je vous propose de régaler
de regarder ce magazine a réalisé avec
elodie moines et patrick jacques de
dixmude
en septembre les foires aux vins
fleuriste en france l'occasion de
s'intéresser au marché du vin nous
allons rencontrer des vendeurs mais
aussi un producteur yvelinois au sein
d'une association
et pour commencer direction la vignerie
un espace de vente situés à rambouillet
les premières foires aux vins ont vu le
jour au supermarché il ya 40 ans depuis
c'est devenu une tradition selon un
sondage pour le magazine health à deux
français sur trois ont l'intention de
participer à une foire cette année pour
la vignery c'est évidemment un rendez
vous à ne pas manquer déjà que vous êtes
responsable de la vignery
c'est ce mois ci la foire aux vins alors
c'est quoi le concept c'est une grande
braderie
oui tout à fait c'est une mise en avant
de
d'essentiellement de la région bordeaux
sur le millésime de sortie 2011 et 2010
avec des promotions et des prix plus
attractifs que le reste de l'année ici
pas l'espace aménagé pour l'occasion la
vignerie repose sur un concept
particulier entre l'hypermarché le
caviste de gros volumes d'achat mais une
sélection et une vente par des
sommeliers au niveau de la vignerie vous
avez su vous développez vous avez huit
magasins en france comment vous
expliquer cette réussite finalement on a
les avantages du caviste avec la
présence de sommelier qui sont là pour
guider les clients en magasin
et puis pour le côté grande distribution
on a un large choix et surtout des prix
qui sont attractifs pour les autres
espaces de vente donc que ce soit qui
avait indépendante où il y perd est ce
que le secteur se porte également aussi
bien je pense que c'est un secteur
qu'ils étaient amassés difficile
notamment dans l'est pour les cavistes
indépendants ou à beaucoup de petit caïd
de quartier ferment régulièrement en
grande distribution
je pense que c'est un marché qui est
quand même plus difficile qu'auparavant
du fait que les prix ont beaucoup
flamber sur les millésimes de sortie
comme 2009 et 2010 comment ça s'explique
c'était deux très beaux millésimes 2009
2010 où les prix ont flambé les gens ont
tendance à acheter peut-être un peu
moins du fait de l'augmentation des prix
même si les chiffres d'affaires ont été
moins importants l'année dernière dans
les supermarchés les magasins leclerc
ayons réalisé 12,2 pour cent des ventes
annuelles du rayon vins au chant 15%
il y a encore quelques années les foires
aux vins étaient strictement réservé à
cette grande distribution mais les
choses ont changé nous sommes ici à la
cave à vin chez jean-marc carboni et
c'est la période des foires aux vins ça
a été inventé dans les années 70 par les
hypermarchés les cavistes indépendants
s'ils mettent petit à petit il est votre
position par rapport à ça bah non en
fait on en profite également aujourd'hui
ça a démarré par la bande de grands
bordeaux des grands crus classés
les choses intéressantes aujourd'hui ça
commence à être un peu moins mais nous
on en profite les cavistes pour faire
également des foires aux vins vous
pensez c'est finalement une bonne chose
ça permet d'apporter une plus grande
clientèle
cela profite principalement aux hypers
et supermarchés c'est ça profite plus
aux hypermarchés bien sûr mais nous les
gens sont curieux viennent chez nous
quand même bien de chez les cavistes
pour voir ce qui se passe ce qu on dit
en général c'est que les français
cherchent un peu plus la qualité dans le
vin est ce qu ils viennent donc du coup
plus chez les cavistes indépendants
aujourd'hui de nos jours est ce que vous
ressentez en fait une plus grosse
clientèle à écouter gérant lui dire il
ya de clientèle dans les hypers ont leur
clientèle et kirghizstan indépendant ont
leur clientèle
mais qui c'est vrai que on commence à
avoir de plus en plus de gens qui
viennent quand même chez caviste pour
trouver d'autres produits d chez les
cavistes indépendants notamment et
surtout au moment des fêtes
c'est à dire si on a une occasion
particulière au moment de noël on n'en
peut plus de se faire plaisir des gens
qui ont l'habitude tout année d'aller en
grande surface parce que c'est plus
facile aussi on fait ses courses on
achète une bouteille mais au moment de
noël on a vraiment envie de se faire
plaisir et là on vient chez les cavistes
alors comment vous vous différencie par
rapport aux structures vous avez une
proposer des vins complètement différent
des bains où il sans problème ou bien
sûr je travaille je travaille pas quand
même union les cavistes indépendants qui
aiment leur métier qui sont passionnés
ne travaille pas avec les mêmes opinions
que l'on trouve en grande surface assez
évident l'appellation ne fait pas tout
voilà dans l'appellation il ya plusieurs
catégories de vignerons et
donc on travaille pas forcément avec les
mêmes heureusement certains avancent
qu'il y a trop d'offre sur le marché et
que sap long d'un petit peu finalement
le secteur du vin aujourd'hui
complètement les choses qui a beaucoup
beaucoup trop d'offres quand on regarde
les catalogues et c'est hallucinant tout
ce qu'on peut voir des seins fumions on
sait pas d'où ils sortent enfin des prix
des synthés millions à 5 euros la
bouteille
c'est ça va ça me choque un peu quand
même hein c'est dû à quoi
bah en fait je pense qu'à la crise un
peu en partie un peu responsable aussi
certains certains vignerons connaît sa
crise et qui baissent leurs prix
ivey a surpris bien sûr et même la
plupart des clients sont encore surtout
français encore un peu impose un peu
snob et il aime bien avoir une belle
étiquette sur sa table moi je ferai avec
des vignerons qui se mettent au service
de leur terroir
il ya un coup c'est un travail toute
l'année dans la vigne un travail de la
vie de viticulture très pointue et tout
ça c'est un coup et ça peut on peut pas
sortir sa ceinture aussi on a passé deux
tours n'a pas la qualité d'un
saint-émilion à ce prix là c'est pas
possible
au 19ème siècle et de france et est la
première région productrice de vin
aujourd'hui il ne reste plus qu'une
vigne commercial à suresnes dans les
yvelines
on ne compte que quelques vignes
municipales ou associatives comme celle
de saint-arnaud elle a été planté il ya
près de dix ans par gérald vernez son et
d'autres amoureux des vignobles
la municipalité nous a prêté ce terrain
qui est orientée sud donc l'idéal
légèrement en pente pour les commander
au et nous avons planté 1260 pieds de
chardonnay
chaque semaine des bénévoles de son
association se relaient pour entretenir
ces deux mille mètres carrés gérald
aurait bien aimé pouvoir planter plus de
pied mais la réglementation est assez
stricte difficile donc d'imaginer un
retour du vin d'ile-de-france et les
restrictions législatives ne sont pas
l'unique problème vous manque un peu de
soleil quand même et puis il faut il
faut que le terrain soit propice là il
ya eu beaucoup amendé le terrain pour
qu'ils puissent recevoir le cépage
chardonnay que nous avons planté et donc
on va faire deux rouges parce que le ya
pas assez de soleil
le terrain n'est pas assez calcaire donc
on a privilégié le sepa jardin du blanc
sec donc ici l'année dernière le raisin
a été attaquée cette année s'annonce
différente si le temps continue comme ça
pas trop pluvieux du soleil surtout là
pour que ça sèche ça va être une belle
récolte le printemps maussade a retardé
la récolte il faudra attendre fin
octobre à ce moment là les 150 adhérents
de l'association se retrouveront dans la
cour de la mairie pour presser le vin du
pressoir il coule directement dans la
cave ou plutôt dans les anciennes
prisons de la ville donc voilà cadre le
vin arrive par cette trappe pour
atteindre les cuves mais pour le
déguster il faudra attendre fin mai et
début juin
peu d'espoir donc de retrouver des
bouteilles évinoise dans le commerce
et puis on le rappelle est bien évident
amour il cela reste une boisson à
consommer avec modération
on passe maintenant à l'agenda deux
dates à retenir les 17 et 18 septembre
des jobs dating sont organisées à
l'espace philippe noiret aux
clayes-sous-bois ou année celle et ses
enseignes aux recherches
800 personnes les inscriptions sont à
envoyer à recrutement à taiwan les
chaînes point fr c'est la fin de ce fil
et commercy d'avoir été avec nous je
vous retrouve la semaine prochaine pour
un prochain numéro
bonne soirée